>> Laura: I'M LAURA INGRAHAM,
THIS IS "HANNITY" FROM
WASHINGTON TONIGHT.
IF YOU CAN'T BEAT THEM, INDICT
THEM.
THAT IS THE FOCUS OF TONIGHT'S
ANGLE.
NOW IN SPORTS, IF YOU ARE A
COACH WITHOUT A WINNING RECORD
EVENTUALLY GET FIRED.
IF YOU ARE A CEO AND YOU CAN'T
RETURN VALUE TO THE
SHAREHOLDERS, YOU GET FIRED.
BUT FOR LIBERALS AND POLITICS IN
THE MEDIA, BEING WRONG
CONSISTENTLY IS RARELY A
DISQUALIFIER.
NOT FROM RUNNING FOR OFFICE TO
PUSH THE SAME POLICIES THAT HAVE
ALREADY FAILED AND NOT FROM
APPEARING ON TV TO MAKE MORE BAD
PREDICTIONS.
SUCH IS THE CASE WITH ALL THE
SMUG LOG HEADS FORECAST AND THE
POLITICAL DEMISE OF
DONALD TRUMP.
>> I DO THINK TRUMP IS WAITING.
>> HE'S ONLY BEEN OUT OF OFFICE
FOR TEN MONTHS, SO YOU ALREADY
SEE HIS INFLUENCE DEFINITELY
WAYNE.
WE WERE GOING TO SEE THAT
CONTINUE IN THE NEXT THREE
YEARS.
>> DONALD TRUMP IS HAVING A BAD
MORNING BECAUSE HE HAS BECOME
IRRELEVANT.
>> Laura: NEVER TRUMPER
REPUBLICANS NEVER KNOWN FOR
THEIR ORIGINALITY REPEATED THE
MANTRA.
>> WE ARE STARTING TO SEE SOME
OF TRUMP'S INFLUENCE, THE RIFT
ON THE REPUBLICAN PARTY IS
STARTING TO LOOSEN.
>> WE KNOW TRUMP'S INFLUENCE IS
WANING.
>> TRUMP'S INFLUENCE IS
DIMINISHING.
>> Laura: THAT IS WHAT IS
CALLED WISHFUL THINKING, FOLKS.
BECAUSE THEY DESPERATELY WANTED
TRUMP GONE.
THEY LET WHATEVER A SLIVER OF
POLITICAL JUDGMENT THEY HAD IF
THEY HAD ANY TO BEGIN WITH.
CHECK OUT THIS MAP OF STATES
WHERE TRUMP ENDORSED CANDIDATES
HAVE WON IN SENATE RACES.
FOR THOSE OF YOU KEEPING SCORE
AT HOME, THAT IS 80, RECORD AND
THE SENATE PRIMARIES, AND THE
HOUSE PRIMARIES, HIS RECORD IS
14 WINS AND FIVE LOSSES.
THAT IS AN OVERALL SUCCESS RATE
FOR SENATE HOUSE AND GOVERNORS
OF 95% FOR INCUMBENTS AND 70%
FOR NONINCUMBENTS.
THAT WINNING PERCENTAGE SHOULD
BECOME EVEN MORE BIG WITH THE
NOW EXPECTED VICTORY OF CAREY
LAKE IN ARIZONA AFTER TONIGHT'S
NEW BATCH OF COUNTED VOTES.
WHATEVER YOU THINK OF TRUMP'S
POLICIES, HIS PERSONALITY, DOES
ALL OF THAT LOOK LIKE THE RECORD
OF SOMEONE WITH WANING POLITICAL
INFLUENCE?
NOW THE ESTABLISHMENT OF YOU
AGAIN IS WRONG ON SO MANY
ISSUES.
IT WAS THAT TRUMP WAS BAD FOR
THE G.O.P., THEY SAID THAT OVER
AND OVER, MINORITIES WOULD RUN
FROM HIM.
WELL, THAT IS NOT PANNING OUT
EITHER.
WHEN IT COMES TO MINORITIES THE
OPPOSITE IS THE CASE.
THEY ARE MORE FAVORABLY INCLINED
TO REPUBLICANS THAN EVER BEFORE.
SPEAK OF THE DEMOCRATS HAVE A
HISTORY OF ENDURING WHAT
HISPANICS REALLY WANT AND
WHAT THEY WANT IS TO PROTECT
THEIR FAMILY, THEY WANT THE LAWE
TO PROTECT THEIR FAITH AND THEY
LOVE THIS COUNTRY AND BELIEVE IN
AMERICAN DREAM.
>> Laura: NOW REPUBLICANS VIEW
THEIR OWN PARTY MORE FAVORABLY
THAN IN THE PRETRUMP YEARS.
IF THAT IS TRUMP WITH DIMINISHED
INFLUENCE I WOULD HATE TO SEE
TRUMP WITH -- INFLUENCE.
WHATEVER TRUMP DECIDES TO DO IN
2024, HIS IDEAS ARE WHAT IS THE
REAL THREAT TO THE SWAMP.
ALL THOSE NEVER TRUMPER NINNIES
KNOW THAT IN HIS SECOND TERM HIS
AGENDA WOULD BE SUMMED UP IN ONE
SENTENCE: NO MORE MR. NICE GUY.
ON THE CHOPPING BLOCK WOULD BE
THE WAR ON FOSSIL FUELS, ALL
THINGS WOKE AT THE PENTAGON,
THAT'S A GONE.
PRO-CHINA BIAS AT THE NIH IS
GONE AND FEDERAL EMPLOYEES WHO
REFUSED TO RETURN TO WORK.
THE LATTER IS AN EXISTENTIAL
THREAT TO THE D.C. BUREAUCRACY.
THE SHEER SIZE OF THE FEDERAL
CIVIL SERVICE IS COMPRISED OF A
STAGGERING 2.1 MILLION
EMPLOYEES.
WHEN MOST AMERICANS HEAR THAT,
THEY ARE SHOCKED TO KNOW OF THE
ACTUAL SIZE OF THE FEDERAL
BEACH.
TOP TO BOTTOM REFORM OF THE
FEDERAL SERVICES TERRIFYING, TO
THE THOUSANDS OF LAZY GOVERNMENT
EMPLOYEES WHO ARE USED TO DOING
NOTHING AND GETTING PAID FOR IT.
THE OFFICE OF PERSONNEL
MANAGEMENT WEBSITE, I WENT ON IT
TODAY, REMINDS US THE ORIGINAL
CIVIL SERVICE ACT SIGNED IN 1883
AND AT THE SPOILS SYSTEM AND
ESTABLISHED THE CIVIL SERVICE
COMMISSION.
IT LED BY THE ENERGETIC TEDDY
ROOSEVELT LAID THE FOUNDATION OF
THE NAME PARTIAL SERVICE BASED
ON THE MERIT PRINCIPLE, THAT
EMPLOYEES SHOULD BE JUDGED ONLY
ON HOW WELL THEY CAN DO THE JOB.
THAT'S GOOD.
TODAY, TEDDY HAS TO BE ROLLING
IN HIS GRAVE.
OVERWHELMINGLY THE CIVIL SERVICE
ASKED NOT AS AN UNBIASED
WORKFORCE BUT AS AN ARM OF THE
DEMOCRATIC NATIONAL COMMITTEE.
TRUMP KNOWS THIS, HE LIVED IT.
LEFTISTS WHO WERE BURROWED INTO
AGENCIES AND DEPARTMENTS WERE
CONSTANTLY UNDERMINING HIS
AGENDA.
THUS THEY WERE THWARTING THE
WILL OF THE PEOPLE WHO ELECTED
DONALD TRUMP.
TALK ABOUT ANTIDEMOCRATIC.
THAT IS WHAT THE DEMOCRATS ARE
ALWAYS SCREAMING ABOUT.
THAT IS ANTIDEMOCRATIC.
AS FOR WITH THE TRUMP IS
INFLUENTIAL, HIS VIEWS STILL
ARE.
ACCORDING TO AXIOS, SEVERAL
POSSIBLE 2024 G.O.P.
PRESIDENTIAL CANDIDATES SAY THEY
SUPPORT TRUMP'S PLAN TO MAKE IT
EASIER FOR THE PRESIDENT TO
PURGE FEDERAL WORKERS.
WHY DOES THAT MATTER?
TRUMP NEED NOT WINS PARTY'S
NOMINATION OR RUN AGAINST, THE
NEXT YEAR HE WILL BE PRESIDENT
TO TRY TO REIMPOSE THE EXECUTIVE
ORDER KNOWN AS SCHEDULE F.
DEMOCRATS INCREASINGLY CONCERNED
ARE SCRAMBLING TO BLOCK THAT
POSSIBILITY.
YEAH, YOU BET.
THAT CONCERN ON THE PART OF THE
DEMOCRATS OF CIVIL SERVICE
REFORM IS ONLY GROWING.
JUST LIKE THEY NEEDED AN
INSURANCE POLICY TO STOP TRUMP
FROM WINNING IN 2016, THE SAME
FORCES FEEL LIKE THEY NEED
ANOTHER INSURANCE POLICY NOW.
AND IT MIGHT ARRIVE COURTESY OF
A BLATANTLY POLITICAL DOJ
INVESTIGATION INTO JANUARY 6TH.
19 MONTHS AFTER THE CAPITOL
RIOTS AND THEY SUDDENLY IMPANEL
A FEDERAL GRAND JURY TO EXAMINE
POTENTIAL CRIMINALITY
SURROUNDING JANUARY 6TH?
IT IS BEYOND OBVIOUS THEY ARE
WORRIED THAT TRUMP IS NOT JUST
GOING TO RUN AGAIN BUT THAT HE
IS GOING TO WIN AGAIN.
AND RATHER THAN TAKE HIM ON A
COURT OF IDEAS, THEY WANT TO
TAKE THEM OFF THE COURT
ALTOGETHER.
>> THIS COMMITTEE IS DOING ITS
JOB.
THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE NEEDS
TO DO THERE IS.
>> THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE HAS
A DUTY TO ACT ON THIS REFERRAL
AND OTHERS.
>> I WILL ECHO WHAT MY
COLLEAGUES HAVE ALREADY SAID,
BUT MORE BLUNTLY,
ATTORNEY GENERAL GARLAND, DO
YOUR JOB SO THAT WE CAN DO OURS.
>> Laura: SO THAT YOU CAN DO
YOURS?
REALLY?
CHECK THE INFLATION NUMBERS,
SWEETIE, AIN'T DOING ANYTHING.
YOU KNOW THEY ARE PANICKED WHEN
THE GHOST FROM ADMINISTRATIONS
PAST START POPPING UP TO NADJA
GARLAND NADJA GARLAND.
>> MY GUESS IS BY THE END OF
THIS PROCESS YOU ARE GOING TO
SEE INDICTMENTS INVOLVING
HIGH-LEVEL PEOPLE IN THE
WHITE HOUSE, YOU'RE GOING TO SEE
INDICTMENTS OF PEOPLE OUTSIDE
THE WHITE HOUSE AND ULTIMATELY
YOU WILL PROBABLY SEE THE FORMER
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES
INDICTED AS WELL.
>> Laura: THAT IS RICH COMING
FROM THE MASTER OF THE
OBAMA-HILLARY COVER UP.
BUT THE ONLY THING THAT WAS
IRONIC, IT WAS REALLY IRONIC
WHEN DARTH VADER SHOWED UP HERE
>> OUR NATION'S 246 YEAR HISTORY
THERE'S NEVER BEEN AN INDIVIDUAL
WHO WAS A GREATER THREAT TO OUR
REPUBLIC THAN DONALD TRUMP.
LIZ IS FEARLESS, NEVER BACKS
DOWN FROM A FIGHT.
THERE IS NOTHING MORE IMPORTANT
SHE WILL EVER DO THAN LEAD THE
EFFORT TO MAKE SURE DONALD TRUMP
IS NEVER AGAIN NEAR THE
OVAL OFFICE.
AND SHE WILL SUCCEED.
>> Laura: THE WHOLE THING
ABOUT NEVER GOING INTO POLITICS
AGAIN IS FUNNY BECAUSE THAT IS
THE SORT OF STUFF HIS NEWFOUND
FRIENDS ON THE LEFT USED TO SAY
ABOUT HIM.
>> HANDING OUT BILLIONS OF
DOLLARS IN CONTRACTS WITHOUT A
BID TO HALLIBURTON WHILE YOU ARE
STILL ON THE PAYROLL MAKES YOU
UNFIT TO LEAVE THIS COUNTRY.
>> YOU CAN ALWAYS TELL WHEN THE
REPUBLICANS ARE RESTLESS BECAUSE
THE VICE PRESIDENT'S MOTORCADE
PULLS INTO THE CAPITAL AND
DARTH VADER EMERGES.
>> Laura: AND REMEMBER THESE
HEADLINES?
REMEMBER THOSE?
I AM CONFUSED, THAT IS THAT GUY
EVERYONE IS NOW SUPPOSED TO
LISTEN TO ON INDICTMENT?
OKAY.
WHAT YOU ARE SEEING THIS WEEK IS
JUST ANOTHER EXAMPLE OF THE
ESTABLISHMENT'S PRIMARY EMOTION
THESE DAYS.
PANIC.
YOU KNOW THE ECONOMY IS DOING
POORLY, THEY KNOW THEIR FOREIGN
POLICIES FAILING, THEY KNOW
THEIR FOREIGN POLICY HURTS
AMERICAN WORKERS AND THEY KNOW
AMERICA IS GETTING WEAKER AND
THEY KNOW AN ELECTION IS COMING
UP IN 2024.
AND THEY KNOW WE ARE ON TO THEM
BECAUSE OVER THE NEXT TWO YEARS
YOU CAN EXPECT MORE WILD CHARGES
AND THREATENED RESIGNATIONS,
INVESTIGATIONS AND BAD
PREDICTIONS.
BUT DON'T LOSE HOPE, WE ARE O